vie sociale enfin un premier mort en
Vélib'
oh Stéphane Dion
[Applaudissements]
et voilà
mon petit Stéphane ça va
ça va
voici la semaine de Stéphane Million
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors mon petit Stéphane
il y a un papier gratuitement méchant
aujourd'hui Thierry pour les amateurs
d'humour noir la Toussaint est une fête
nationale et j'ai essayé de faire
plaisir
ça gaz fut le tout dernier mot d'un
bistrotier à Bondy
la finale de volley à 6 s'est tenue en
Bosnie cul-de-jatte et unijambiste se
sont affrontés un sport très populaire
au Rwanda avec 100.000 licenciés en
France ça décolle pas trop trop
personnelle ça prend pas quoi
[Applaudissements]
mercredi c'était Halloween aux
États-Unis une société lance le masque
Michael Jackson
en France ou le masque Régine n'est
toujours pas sorti
politique inquiétude après le départ de
Cécilia Nicolas alterne des phases
d'euphorie totale comme ici au Maroc où
il se déguise en Tom Cruise
avec des phases de déprime profonde deux
jours plus tard sous la pluie il demande
à observer des canards
tout est fait pour lui redonner le moral
augmenter son salaire ou encore faire
des paris à la con rouler une pelle à
Rachida Dati
faire de l'auto tamponneuse en pleine
grève des transports
[Rires]
on continue dans la déprime la nouvelle
vie de Chirac titre Le Parisien pose
bière et balade avec sumo
[Rires]
se promener bourré avec un chien par les
temps qui courent c'est pas idéal pourvu
que chez moi n'aille pas bouffé un
nourrisson pendant que Chirac se tape
une mousse
[Applaudissements]
sociale enfin un premier mort en vélib
tout a été fait pour pas de casque
obligatoire couloir de bus dans tous les
sens de la Noé justement récompensée on
le voit comme il a appris la nouvelle
[Musique]
en Seine-Saint-Denis une balle perdue
traverse une salle de classe une façon
rock'n'roll de celebrer Guy Moquet
[Applaudissements]
je viens de tout ça moi sauf que cette
pizza
l'homme de Néandertal avait les cheveux
roux découverte faites grâce au
prélèvement ADN une bonne nouvelle pour
tous les sans-papiers rouquins en cas de
litige dites que vous êtes originaire
des grottes de Lascaux
Adjani présente au meeting touche pas à
mon ADN je pensais qu'ils appellent
défendait l'association touche pas à mon
collagène
télévision
Gérard Jugnot dans Alibaba très beau
casting un regret quand même pourquoi ne
pas avoir pris les dirigeants de ADS
pour incarner les 40 voleurs
[Applaudissements]
Pascal Sevran pourrait animer une
émission de divertissement sur France 2
Sevran on en a dit beaucoup de mal
c'était pas si con son idée de couper la
des noirs on évitait les tests ADN
[Applaudissements]
à la tête de l'équipe de France
dorénavant sur tous les cours de tennis
avant de jouer il faudra lire la lettre
de Guy Forget
et on termine on termine par une
déclaration de Nikos Aliagas dans match
je lave le cerveau des tracas du
quotidien
on préfère les tracas du quotidien la
grève les chiens qui bouffent les bébés
tout sauf Nikos Aliagas
merci et
excellent cimetière à tous et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu